Our distinguished speaker this evening,
Dennis Hassabis
cofounded,
the artificial intelligence lab deep
mind,
and it's recognized worldwide as one of
the smartest thinkers in his field.
He was nicknamed the superhero of
artificial intelligence by the Guardian.
He's a former chess prodigy with degrees
in computer science and cognitive.
This is making me sweat.
He's so.
He's so clever.
Anyway,
this evening's topic,
creativity,
an ai draws on his eclectic experiences
as an artificial intelligence
researcher,
neuroscientists,
and video game designer to discuss the
implications of cutting edge research
for creativity and scientific discovery.
There'll be an opportunity for questions
at the end.
I think,
um,
I think tim was probably handling that
as a writer.
Anyway.
Without further ado,
I'd love you to give a big welcome to
Dennis [inaudible] office.
Thank you.
Thank you Chris for that introduction.
So it's a great honor for me to be here
at the academy to give this inaugural
Rothschild's lecture in this wonderful
and inspiring amphitheater that we're
sitting in today.
I always love visiting there all academy
and I think it's great to have these
kinds of dialogues between the sciences
and the arts and I think it's actually
going to become increasingly more vital
as we rush headlong into the modern
technological world.
So today I'm going to explore a theme
that's the heart of everything at the
wall academy,
namely creativity,
and I'm going to examine it through the
lens of science and also more
specifically through the lens of the
latest advances advances in artificial
intelligence.
So as all of you will know,
ai is the science of making machines
smart.
And as Chris mentioned,
we found a deep mind in 2010 with the
goal of trying to advance artificial
intelligence.
And we thought of AI and deep mind as a
kind of an Apollo program.
Efforts to advance ai as quickly as
possible.
And what we mean by that is try to bring
together the world's greatest research.
Scientists and engineers.
Give them all the resources they
require,
compute power and other things in order
to see how much progress we could make
towards solving ai.
And we had an ambitious roadmap that
we're carrying out to this day.
The other big thing,
idea behind deep mind and vision behind
it was to try and organize scientific
endeavor in a new way.
So the way I can kind of summarize that
is we try to fuse together the best from
academia,
blue sky thinking and ambitious thinking
that you get in the best place with
academia,
with the best from the startup world.
So the kind of focus and energy and pace
that you get at the world's best
startups.
And we didn't see why those two types of
environments had to be mutually
exclusive.
And we thought that we could advance
science more quickly if we could combine
the best from both of those worlds.
Now mission at deep mind,
we articulated as a kind of to step
mission.
So step one,
fundamentally solve intelligence.
So we'd like to understand what
intelligence is and we create it
artificially.
And then we believe if you do step one
and a general enough way,
then step two naturally follows.
We should be able to use this technology
to solve almost everything else.
And that might sound a little bit
fanciful,
but I hope that by the end of the talk
of hope to have convinced you to at
least think that maybe this is not so
far fetched after all,
uh,
perhaps actually it's a logical next
step after we have general artificial
intelligence.
So more prosaically we plan to do this
by building the world's first general
purpose learning system.
So what do those words mean?
General and learning?
Well,
let me take you through two main
approaches.
Two main approaches to building ai kind
of falls between two schools of fault.
So in the early days of artificial
intelligence,
the main approach was,
is what's called expert systems.
Sometimes it's called good old fashioned
ai.
These days I'd go fly or traditional Ai,
you could think of it.
And on the left hand side here,
that's what what's involved is that we,
you know,
teams are programmers and researchers
hardcode knowledge in the form of rules
that they express in complex databases.
And you can imagine this sort of series
of thousands of if then rules trying to
encapsulate the solution to whatever
problem the program is supposed to be
dealing with.
Now the,
the,
the issue with those types of those
types of systems is they can't generally
deal with the unexpected and they're
quite brittle because of that.
So they're limited to the solutions that
have been pre programmed in them.
They can't think for themselves and they
can't deal with anything that they
weren't already prepared for.
So what this means is they're limited to
solutions that we can express as the
programmers.
So the program has themselves have to
understand in new detail what the
solution is in order to handcraft
encodes the Hanco these knowledge
systems.
So these expert systems were inspired by
logic systems,
logic theory.
If we now compare that to modern day
learning systems and which is sort of
the advent of has been one of the
reasons behind the rejuvenation and the
revolution in artificial intelligence in
the last decade is because these
learning systems are now really starting
to work and learning systems.
They learned solutions from first
principles,
they learned directly from data and
directly from experience and they learn
for themselves so they're not
preprogrammed with solutions.
They have to figure out solutions for
themselves and if we can build these
systems in a gentle enough way,
they can generalize to new tasks they've
never seen before and perhaps even solve
things that we don't know how to
ourselves,
and that's the really amazing promise of
these systems is they could go beyond
the knowledge that we have ourselves and
also it's of interesting domains which
I'm going to talk about later in this
lecture and in the main learning systems
are inspired by neuroscience and
informed by neuroscience and how the
brain works and that's where we get a
lot of our inspiration from for the for
building these types of architectures.
So expert systems are inspired by logic
and learning.
Systems are inspired by the brain.
Now,
still,
the most famous example of an expert
system was IBM's deep blue computer that
beat Garry Kasparov in the late nights
in the late nineties,
who was at the time he was the world
champion of chess,
which I'm sure all of you remember now.
This was obviously a very impressive
technical feat.
And I remember this match very well.
Um,
I was doing my undergraduate at
Cambridge and we were sort of watching
this match.
Um,
and as you can imagine,
I was extremely interested in this from
both from the chest side and the
computer science side.
And what I remember coming away from was
actually,
although it's an impressive technical
feat,
I came away from this match more
impressed by Garry Kasparov,
mind than I was by the machine because
he was gary,
you know,
this amazing sort of creative genius,
uh,
probably one of the best,
if not the best chess player of all
time.
And he was able to more or less hold his
own against this big brute of a machine.
It was a huge super computer with
obviously teams are program programmers
behind it with all these rules
programmed into it and not only was he
able to compete on a more or less level
footing with the machine here cause he
can do all the other things that we can
do as humans.
He could speak three languages,
drive a car,
or ride a bike.
All of these other things that we can
marry out of things that we're able to
do.
And if you compare that to deep blue,
which is obviously amazing at chess,
I'm the blue,
could not even play a strictly simpler
game,
say like noughts and crosses without
being totally reprogrammed.
So nothing in the knowledge base of deep
blue would help it do anything else.
So it was this hard coded specialized
system that was only good for one thing
playing chess.
And it seemed to me that,
you know,
in terms of thinking about intelligence,
something was missing here,
some critical things was we're missing
here.
And what I believe was missing were
these two notions.
This notion of learning and this notion
of generality and both of those things
were missing from deep blue and expert
systems in general.
And when I saw this match in after this
match,
one of the things I resolved to do is to
one day build a general games playing
machine that could play any game out of
the box.
So let's look at what's been happening
with learning systems and actually the
system,
the kind of framework we think about
intelligence in at deep mind is a
framework called reinforcement learning.
And um,
the idea behind reinforcement learning
is that these systems,
these agents,
we call them the AI systems,
that deep mind learn from first
principles through trial and error.
So that's how they build up knowledge
about the world.
And I'm just going to show you with the
aid of a simple diagram how these
systems work at very high level.
So first of all,
we start with the agent system.
The AI system here on the left,
and the agent finds itself in some kind
of environment.
Now the environment could be the real
world,
in which case the agent,
you can think of it as a robot,
a physical robot or the environment can
be in virtual environment like a game or
simulation,
a computer simulation,
in which case the agent would be like an
Avatar in that game environment.
And the agent has been given a goal by
the designers,
uh,
to,
to achieve within that environment.
Now,
the agent only interacts with the
environment in two ways.
So firstly through it sensory operators
and we normally use vision,
but you could use other modalities like
audition and touch.
Um,
but we use vision and you get these
observations about the environment
through your senses.
And the observations also include
rewards from the environment for doing
the right things.
And the first job of the agent system is
to build up a model of the world out
there,
the environment now then how it works.
So it's got to figure out a statistical
model about the environment it finds
itself in and,
and the linkages in that environment.
And once it has a model of the world
which is continually updating based on
your observations,
then the second job of the agent system
is to pick the right action to take.
So at any moment in time,
I'm the agent system,
I have a whole array of actions
available to it and it's got to select
the best action that will get it closest
towards achieving its goal at that
moment in time.
And if the model of the world,
the agent has is very good,
it can hypothesize in its mind what the
consequences of doing certain actions
will be and what the likely change in
the environment will be.
And you can think of this system in a
cycle.
So the agent,
once it runs out thinking time.
So this is all a realtime system
outputs.
The best action is found so far.
The action gets executed and then that
may drive a new change in the
environment,
which then drives a new observation.
And then the agent updates his model of
the world and then selects a new action.
And this goes on in an incremental
fashion until eventually through
sophisticated sort of trial error
processes,
the agent reaches its goal.
Now though I started com,
looks quite simple.
There's actually a huge amount of
technical complexity behind this that
needs to be sold.
Very complex technical challenges.
But we know that if we could solve all
those challenges,
this framework of reinforcement learning
is enough to give us general
intelligence and we know that because
this is how the brain works.
And um,
in fact,
in,
in the,
in the primate and human brain is the
dopamine system and dopamine neurons,
they implement a form of reinforcement
learning and that actually allow us to
learn using this system of reinforcement
based on rewards.
So how did we develop this further?
Well,
the first work we did is partly because
of my background in my previous career
of designing video games and building ai
systems for,
for video games.
Um,
I realized that games would be the
perfect proving ground for developing
and testing ai algorithms.
Normally when you work on ai,
you often work with robotics.
But the problem with robotics is,
and we love robotics as an application
area for ai,
but as a development platform it's quite
tricky because you end up spending most
of your time on the hardware,
you know,
dealing with the server motors on the
robots and they always break and they're
quite slow and they're very expensive to
use.
Um,
and in fact it's much more convenient to
use virtual simulations like games and
actually test the sophistication of your
Ai Algorithms in,
in those simulations.
So we,
we started with games and in fact we
started with the most iconic,
sort of the first iconic game console,
which was the Atari Twenty 600,
which some of you may remember from the
eighties and we,
it was the first,
we'll sort of,
big console game that had a big
diversity of,
of games on it,
very,
very different sorts of games.
And we tested our system,
our first system back in 2013 on these
Atari Games.
Before we show you a video that of the,
of the system working,
I just want to explain to you what it is
that you're going to see.
So the agent system,
which we call Dqn,
I'm only gets the raw pixels as inputs,
so I'm only gets the pixels on the
screen,
the kind of values of the colors of the
pixels on the screen as inputs it isn't
told anything else about the game.
Everything else is learned from scratch.
It doesn't know what he's controlling.
It doesn't know how to get points.
All it knows is here's a stream of
numbers,
30,000
numbers per frame and the goal is to
maximize the score,
doesn't know anything else about what
it's supposed to do,
so it has to learn everything else from
scratch.
And then the,
the final sort of challenge if you like,
is this notion of generality.
So we wanted one single system to be
able to play all the different games out
of the box.
So I'm going to show you my favorite
video,
the Atari stuff working,
which is this game called breakout,
which is one of those seminal games on
the Atari.
And in this game you control the bat to
the bottom of the screen here.
This pink bat that goes left and right
and you've got to bounce this little
pink ball here,
this little pixel here on the left
against this rainbow colored wall and
the idea of the game is you've got to
knock out all the bricks in the wall and
you've got five lives and you can't
allow the ball to go past the bat.
Otherwise you lose a life.
So I'm just gonna run the video here and
you'll see the system improving over
time as it gets more experienced playing
more games and starts to figure out
what's happening in the game.
So this is what it looks like after 100
games and you can see the system is
starting to get the hang of what is
supposed to be doing.
So supposed to move the bat towards the
ball,
but it's missing the ball most of the
time,
but they're starting to get the idea
that maybe it's a good idea to move the
bat towards the ball.
And then after 300 games.
So now you can see it's about as good as
any human can play this.
And it almost never misses the ball
anymore,
even when it's coming back very fast
angles.
So we thought,
wow,
this is great.
But what happens if we left it playing
for another 200 games?
And to our surprise,
what it did is it found this optimal
strategy,
which was to dig a tunnel around the
lefthand side and then send the ball
behind the brick wall,
which was sort of an amazing solution to
the problem in a way.
And of course,
um,
a,
you know,
it's sort of very low risk of the ball
camp go past your bat and it's very
highly rewarding cause he hit many
bricks with just one shot.
So when we saw this,
this was our first have since met since
then,
many Aha moments for us where we
actually learned something from our own
system because the program is,
and the research is behind this,
uh,
amazing researchers,
but they're not so good at playing Atari
Games.
So they didn't really know themselves
about this tactic.
Um,
and obviously it's being executed with
sort of incredible position from the,
from the system.
So then we took these,
these systems and the next thing we
worked on and applied it to was probably
our most famous program called Alphago
and Alphago was our program using these
reinforcement learning ideas,
scaled up even further to play the
ancient game of go and for those you
don't know the game and I encourage you
all to learn.
There's an amazing game that I think
you'd all like,
this is what the board looks like.
It's a very esoteric and artistic game
and it's played on a 19 by 19 grid and
you take turns black and white take
turns to put stones on the vertices of
the of the board,
and the board initially starts empty and
it fills up.
Now the history of go is long and
storied one,
it's over 3000 years old is invented in
China,
has played all over Asia and in fact
it's considered in Asia to be more than
just a game.
It's something more kin to poetry or
art.
In fact,
Confucius wrote about go as one of the
four great arts that any true scholars
should master along with poetry,
calligraphy,
music.
So it's really considered to be one of
these sort of profound arts,
like all of these other artistic
endeavors.
And today it's as popular as ever.
40 million active players,
2000 professionals,
and the game of go is incredibly simple.
I could teach you in five minutes.
There's only two rules,
but the complexity that comes out of it,
it was what makes it so elegant.
And one measure of that complexity is
the fact there are 10 to the power,
170 possible board positions.
So that's a one with 117 zeros after it.
And that's more than there are atoms in
the universe,
right?
So that's the level of complexity just
comes out of these tools.
And,
um,
and that's,
that's what makes the game so deep and
so profound.
Uh,
and,
you know,
again,
sort of these ancient scholars thought
about go is containing some of the
mysteries of the universe in it and
therefore was worthy of this incredible
mouse study.
And of course,
that complexity and uh,
and the esoteric nature of the game is
one of the reasons which makes it so
difficult for computers to play.
And the game of go proceeds one stone at
a time,
when you place it down to the board
fills up like this.
So this is the end of the game.
And the way you determine the winner is
what you're trying to do with your
stones is surround off a wall off empty
areas of territory.
And then you count the number of,
um,
uh,
the number of squares that you've
surrounded compared to your opponent.
And the person that surrounded the most
squares wins the game.
So in this case here,
it's a very close game,
but white winds by one point.
So why is go so hard for computers to
play?
So after deep blue beat Garry Kasparov,
the next big challenge,
the sort of Mount Everest,
if you like,
of um,
computer ai research was go and go,
is much harder than chess for computers.
One,
because of this enormous number of
possibilities that I've just talked
about,
this 10 to 170 possible positions.
So the search base is,
is much,
much bigger than it is for chess,
but the second and kind of even harder
problem is I'm CESC per program chess
engines including deep blue,
rely on what's called an evaluation
function.
So this is one of these handcrafted
rules based systems that tell the
machine which side is winning in the
current position and that's what allows
the blue and it's a and his successes,
his descendants to figure out what the
right move is to play the palm go is
it's such an Easter game,
it's impossible to figure out what the
right set of rules are and encapsulate
that in a rules based system.
Even if you ask top go players,
you know,
why did they make a particular move?
They'll often tell you it just felt
right,
but they won't actually be able to
explicitly tell you themselves why they
pick the move.
Whereas if you ask that to a top chess
player,
they'll almost certainly give you a
specific plan.
They were thinking about,
you know,
I was planning a than I thought it would
happen and I was going to answer.
See now that plan in the end may not be
very good or may fail for some reason,
but they normally have an explicit plan
in go.
It's much more about feel much more how
an artist would think,
and one way to think about that is the
goal is primarily game about about
intuition rather than calculation,
which is more dominant in a game like
chess.
So that's how humans players,
professional players deal with this
enormous complexity and this evaluation
function.
They rely on their instincts and their
intuition.
So we ended up taking a totally
different approach to the way that chess
computers were built.
And we built our Alphago with these
learning systems and we actually
created.
We were to neural networks,
which are loosely based on how the brain
works to deal with these complex
problems.
We create a one your network called the
policy network that takes in the current
ball position and learns through looking
at millions of different games and
playing millions of different millions
of games against itself and seeing and
experiencing millions of games of go.
Um,
what sorts of moods are most likely to
be played in a particular position so
you can think of it taking the current
board position and returning to you,
like the top five most likely moves to
be made.
So that really narrows down this
enormous search base that you need to
explore.
We then have to look at everything
anymore,
like a brute force system would have to.
You can just look at them,
most likely moves.
And then the second thing that was kind
of sort of an unknown whether this could
be done was we built a system that could
take this to the second year network
called the value net here on the right,
the pink network that could take the
current board position and return a
value.
Your probability between zero and one of
who was winning.
So zero would be white,
100 percent likely to win,
a one would be black,
100 percent likely to win and point five
would mean equal position and oversee
over through a course of training of
millions paying millions of games
against itself,
it learns to predict from any position
who is going to win the game and how
confident was in that prediction.
And so by combining these two neural
networks into one system which became
the Alphago System,
we're able to solve these two very
difficult challenges that go presents.
And once we had this system,
we decided to challenge one of the
greatest players ever in go history,
a genius South Korea and grandmaster
called Lisa Doll.
He's eight,
one,
18,
well titles and he was considered to be
the greatest player of the past decade.
And we had a million dollar challenge
match in Seoul,
South Korea,
in back in 2016.
And um,
you know,
before that match,
everybody,
including Lisa doll,
thought it would be a whitewash
whitewash to Lisa doll because until
this point,
no go program had ever even beat in a
professional player,
let alone a world champion.
So,
um,
so all these sort of traditional
techniques that were being used to make
computers,
even though they've been developed for a
further 20 years since the deepblue
match,
they still hadn't got anywhere near to
professional level in go.
So we played this match and over 200
million people across the world watched
the five matches and I'm Alphago
incredibly won the match for one and it
was proclaimed by many experts both in
ai and go to be a decade before its
time,
uh,
and you know,
it was kind of a mentor match that I
think will go down in history in,
in sort of ai as an ai landmark and
there's often been called since then as
a sort of sputnik event for ai,
especially for China and Asia.
But the most important thing is
obviously we are,
Alphago won the match and that's what we
built it for.
But the most interesting thing about the
match was how Alphago won,
um,
and how it played.
So I just want to explain to you a
little bit about Alphago's play.
Even though most of you may not know how
to play.
Go,
I think you can still appreciate what
Alpha go dead.
So this is a board position from game
too,
and this is move 37,
which is probably the most famous move
in the match.
And um,
Alphago is black hair,
it says very early in the game,
at least a dollar is white and Alphago
plays this move here on the right hand
side outlined in red,
this stone here.
And the key thing to notice about where
this stone has been placed is that it's
on the fifth line.
So you can see it's on the fifth line
from the right hand side of the board,
the board's 19 by 19.
Now in the openings,
if you're professional,
you almost always play on the third or
fourth lines.
And that's the most important lines to
be,
um,
to be disputing early on in the game of
go.
So a play on the fifth line this early
on is kind of unthinkable.
No professional player would even
consider this move because it seems
suboptimal and wasteful.
And yet Alphago decided to play here.
And then it turned out the reason the
alpha go played,
there was 100 moves later.
These two stones here in the bottom left
hand corner that I ringed in red,
ended up kind of fighting on the bottom
left here with the board,
ended up spilling all the way into the
middle of the board and moving all
across the board.
And then 100 years later ended up
connecting up perfectly with this stone
on the right hand side and move 37.
And that was ended up being decisive in
that battle.
And at one Alphago the whole game,
right?
So somehow it's as if Alphago had
resigned,
the understood this was gonna happen and
position that stone perfectly for 100
moves into the future.
So of course it will.
The interesting thing is we can all
think about what is creativity,
and I'm going to come and talk a little
bit more about that in the latter part
of this talk,
but we could all play an original movie
in some sense.
Even if we didn't add to play God,
we call just play a random move on the
board and that will be surprising in
some sense,
but the key thing about going is
although it's considered to be an art
form,
it's like objective art,
so a movie is only considered original
and creative if it ends up being
effective and you can measure the
effectiveness,
obviously seeing the result of the game
and then starting that afterwards and
seeing if that move really had a
material difference to the outcome and
you don't have to take my word for it.
You can see this.
I'm just going to play this very short,
that funny clip from the live commentary
stream that was going out to the
millions of players.
There will be watching this on youtube
and I'm on the right hand side.
Here is the strongest player the West
has ever produced.
Michael Redmond,
who's nine damn professional and his
reaction,
he's watching the game live and
commentating on it to seeing this move.
Thirty seven,
so hopefully you'll be your to here.
The Google team was talking about is
this kind of a value?
That's very surprising move.
I thought I thought it was a mistake
so you can hear that he thought it was a
mistake and he goes on to say later in
that clip that he thought it was a
misclick,
so he thought our computer operator had
actually clicked the wrong place on the
board,
the computer board,
because he couldn't believe that Alphago
or would play that move.
Then of course I must mention that Lisa
doll himself came up with his own
incredible,
brilliant moving game for which was the
game that he won,
almost move 78,
which this move in the middle of this
called a wedge move and that has been
analyzed by all the players around the
world.
Both this move and move 37 in the two
years hence.
And they're both being proclaimed to be
amazing moves.
And this move here,
I haven't got time to explain about it,
but it triggered a misvaluation in Alpha
goes networks and that's what allowed
these adults to win,
to win that game.
So for us,
this was a,
an amazing sort of once in a lifetime
experience and it was full of drama for
us and if you're interested to see a
little bit more about the kind of the
human emotions and the spirit of human
endeavor behind this match,
I'd encourage you to watch this
documentary award winning documentary
that done by this brilliant director,
Greg Coast,
which is available on Netflix and you'll
see what went into the match and the
nuances behind it and what the goplayers
thought.
But there's one thing I want to quote
about from there,
which is Lisa Dell's own thoughts and
reflections on move 37 after the match.
The director asked him what he thought
about Alphago and route 37.
And he said,
I thought Alphago is based on
probability calculation and it was
merely a machine.
But when I saw this move,
I changed my mind.
Surely Alphago is creative.
This move was really be creative and
beautiful.
So as really amazing moment and I,
I kind of nearly cried when I saw that
on the film.
After said I didn't see him say that in
the live.
And I thought it was an amazing thing
for him to say,
and,
and very,
uh,
deep of him to realize that.
So I want to now just talk a little bit
about these words I've been using and
throwing around intuition and
creativity.
What do I mean by that?
At least in this context,
and I should caveat this with,
and I'm sure we'll get into this in the
q and a,
that I'm not saying this is,
encompasses all of what we think of is
intuition and creativity.
But I think at least want to think about
operationalizing some of these
definitions so we can discuss it in a
scientific way.
So intuition then the way I think about
intuition,
it's really,
it's implicit knowledge that we have
acquired through experience,
but it's knowledge that's not
consciously expressible or accessible.
So we can't consciously access it and we
can't express it to others.
And that's what,
why it seems a little bit mysterious to
us.
This kind of implicit knowledge.
Now,
of course we know we have it and you can
test the existence in the quality of it
by testing it behaviorally.
You can verify behaviorally and in a,
in a game like go,
it's very easy.
You can give somebody a go position and
ask them to come up with a move and then
evaluate the quality of that move.
So I think that's what it encompasses
more intuition is.
So what about creativity?
Well,
I think one way you could operationalize
the definition of creativity is the
ability to synthesize knowledge to in
the service of producing a novel or
original idea.
And I think under those definitions,
Africa in some sense clearly
demonstrated these abilities during this
match or beer.
Obviously caveated by the fact that it's
still a very constrained domain of a
board game.
But let's think about creativity sort of
more generally.
Here's another definition of creativity
is I think I got out of the Oxford
dictionary the ability to use skill and
imagination to produce something new.
And I think there were at least three
types of creativity or three levels of
creativity if you like.
So the first type,
if you imagine that you're given three
or more examples in a particular topic
and let's imagine for the moment that
the green dots are these examples and
the white box is a particular topic or
field of endeavor and you also create
something new.
So one way you could do that is what I
call interpolation and it's used often
in machine learning and ai as an ai term
and it's Appalachian you can think of is
kind of like an averaging.
So here are three trainings on Paul's,
here are three examples of things we
would like from this world of
possibilities and you kind of find an
average of those things and in some
sense that orange door is new,
right?
It's not,
it's different from the,
from the,
from the examples.
And it's something new,
but it's still sort of contained within
the space.
This green dot,
a green line,
the space that the examples cover,
the next level of creativity,
which is,
you know,
a higher level of creativity would be
extrapolation.
So now you know,
you have those examples,
but instead of just finding an average,
you're extending the boundaries of what
you already know.
So this will be the blue dots and you
can see those three blue dots as outside
of the boundaries that,
that sort of marked out by the training
examples,
the green dots.
And then finally there's what I would
call invention or innovation,
which,
uh,
which is here represented by the yellow
door that's outside the white box
completely.
And this is something completely new,
perhaps informed in some way by what's
inside the box.
Now,
you know,
how,
uh,
how we doing on the Ai Front where these
levels of creativity.
So let's,
let's examine machine creativity and you
know,
neural network systems,
the kind of systems I showed you.
Sometimes the fashionable ones are
called deep learning these days.
They're pretty good interpolation,
you know,
they're massive statistical machines if
you like.
And they're very good at,
uh,
averaging things and spotting patterns
in data.
Then you have things,
Alphago like systems which are getting
pretty good,
I would say extrapolation,
you know,
finding new things beyond the boundaries
of even what the human designers knew
about,
but still within the same general
context.
And then you've got true invention,
which I think no ai systems are anywhere
close to yet,
right?
So this would be,
instead of coming up with an original
moving go,
it will be inventing go right on venting
chess and there's no systems that are
able to do that.
But we can come up with,
you know,
I think Alphago,
uh,
definitely demonstrated extrapolation.
It wasn't just averaging what humans
have done before or mimicking what
humans have done before it was coming
out with genuinely new ideas,
but it can't invent something truly new.
So you might ask,
well,
what's missing?
Well,
although AI systems have been pretty
successful so far,
there's actually a whole bunch of things
that we still need.
I still need to crack.
And things like concepts,
abstract,
abstract thinking,
reasoning by analogy,
memory systems and imagination,
which as we just saw earlier,
is in,
in many of the definitions of
creativity.
And a lot of these terms of these ideas
and capabilities are missing from our
current ai systems and this is where the
cutting edge of ai researchers at the
moment and we're working variously hard
on all these different topics are just
mentioned and I think those things are
key to this invention or this out of the
box thinking because I think a lot of
that comes from interdisciplinary
thinking,
spotting unusual connections between
different subjects and doing things like
imagining counterfactuals right?
So imagine fantastical scenarios and a
lot of our creativity I believe comes
from those capabilities that we
currently don't have in our AI systems.
So where can we look for inspiration?
And I've only got time to cover one of
those topics.
Each one of those could be a whole
lecture in itself,
but I'm just going to talk about a topic
that I've studied for a long time
imagination,
which I think is one of the main keys to
creativity.
And we can actually take our inspiration
from the brain and especially from what
I call a systems neuroscience point of
view,
which is a high level understanding of
the brain.
And interested in the algorithms and the
architecture of the brain uses and I
actually studied memory and imagination
for my phd and I was very interesting.
The question of how do we imagine what
are the brain mechanisms behind
imagination?
And when I started my phd,
one of the things I've started looking
at was how memory works and I became
convinced that memory was a
reconstructive process so you shouldn't
think of memory as a videotape.
It's not a perfect recording.
And if we remember tomorrow we think
back to this lecture or what you had at
lunch today,
it wouldn't be.
It's not really a perfect video tape.
You're actually going to reconstruct it
from its components.
So we reassemble our memories from our
component,
from components and we put them back
together.
So I was thinking if memory,
and there's a lot of evidence that's how
memory works.
So I think if that home is as how memory
works and you can think of memories is
reconstructed process,
then maybe imagination which is a
constructive process.
You're putting these components together
in a novel way.
Maybe it relies on the same brain
mechanisms and the same brain areas,
so we know and we've known for $50 more
than 50 years.
That memory is reliant on an area of the
brain called the hippocampus,
which is shown here in pink and is at
the center of your brain.
And without your hippocampus,
your,
you will become our music.
And that's what happens in terrible
diseases like Alzheimer's.
And so what we thought is why don't we
test some patients who have damage to
the hippocampus,
but the rest of their brains intact on
imagination tasks and see if they can
imagine.
And so what we did is quite a simple
test,
but no one had thought to do this for,
you know,
even though we've been researching
memory for almost a hundred years now.
And we thought to test these patients on
a simple imagination tasks where we got
them to imagine scenarios like imagine
you're lying on a tropical,
a white sandy beach in a beautiful
tropical bay.
Um,
if describe everything you can see
around you.
So this is no problem for healthy
people.
And um,
and we got the patients to,
to describe this and we got age match
than Iq match control subjects to also
describe scenarios.
And what we found is that the patient
descriptions were hugely impoverished
compared to their,
um,
their control cohort.
And you can see here on the right hand
side,
this is a graph of the richness
measuring the richness of their
descriptions.
On the left hand bar is the patient's on
the right hand bar is the control
subjects who their imaginations are a
lot richer.
And what we found after further
investigations is that the problem they
had was they couldn't bind together
disparate elements of a scene into a
whole coherent hole.
So we call this spacial coherence
problem and that's what we think the
hippocampus is actually doing for
imagination.
It's briny together all of these
elements into a hole.
And of course,
you know the imagination.
What does it do for us?
Well,
it's extremely valuable skill that
humans have and allows us to more
accurately predict the future by
hypothesis hypothesizing about different
plans you could do and seeing how they
would turn out.
And also,
I think it's the beginning of creativity
in the sense of allowing us to think of
counterfactual situations related,
did some brain scanning work on healthy
subjects imagining in brain scanners and
we found five different brain areas that
were heavily involved in different
aspects of imagining.
So most recently then we've tried to
recreate this aspect of imagination,
so imagining scenes in our AI systems
and we've recently had some big
breakthroughs on that front and we
created a system called generative query
network,
the Gq n and what the system was able to
do is amazingly kind of reconstruct a
three d model of a scene just from a
handful of Tuesday snapshots.
So imagine giving a the AI system a few
two d pictures of a seen a three d scene
and it recreates the whole three d scene
just from those two stills to those few
today stills.
So then at that point to test the
system,
we ask the system to render the scene
from a new angle.
It's never,
it hasn't seen before.
So we can,
we can ask it to render from any
arbitrary new angle.
So in computer graphics and in Ai
Circles,
this is called the inverse graphics
problem.
So if you imagine computer graphics,
you know,
you have these algorithms and they
produce all these beautiful pictures
that you see in games and in three d
artwork and CGI and there's a
mathematical sort of equations that
basically cre create those three d
scenes on.
What this system is doing is doing the
inverse of that,
the reverse of that.
Here's a three d scene,
here's some pictures of it,
now recover the genitive equations that
actually generate that seat.
So it's called the inverse graphics
problem.
Has been a longstanding problem in
computer graphics.
So the scenes that we were able to do,
um,
I should,
I should say are very simple scenes
currently,
but it's kind of amazing that this works
at all.
So what I'm doing,
I'm just going to show you a quick video
of,
of this working while you're going to
see is these kinds of quite toy like
three d scenes with three,
four,
five objects in it,
geometric objects in it,
like,
you know,
spheres and hemispheres and circles and
so on.
And and,
and boxes of different colors and
different textures.
And what we do is we give the system a
couple of stills snapshots of the scene
and then we tell it to render that from
any new angle.
So I'm going to show you that in this
video here.
So you'll see the scene on the left hand
side here.
So this little box world with these
three objects in there and the system
only gets two snapshots,
view one and view two and then we ask it
to render the view from this new view,
view three coming from another angle and
we would like to see what the image
looks like from that new angle.
So we'll see here.
So it gets given view one that gets
input into the neural network and it
gets processed and it gets represented
inside your network.
Then we give it a new camera angle view
too.
So that's what it looks like from view
to.
We give that to the input and it adds
that to it seemed representation.
And then we ask it.
We queried is why it's called a janitor
query network.
What would it look like from this third
year and now a second year or network
outputs,
the new prediction of what that should
look like,
and then we compare it to the ground
truth,
what it really looks like and you can
see that they almost matched perfectly
and then we're able to spin round.
Um,
we're able to take care from any new
angle,
um,
and then we can give it a new pictures
of new rooms with different objects and
you can see it can move around,
zoom in,
zoom out.
So it's just less if it was a computer
game and we'd completely built a new
graphics engine to do that.
So it's just recovering that from these
two d stills.
Now obviously we're now building up to
scenes of higher complexity and
eventually we would like to get to real
world scenes where you can recreate a
real world seen just from some two d
pictures.
So hopefully I've given you a good
flavor of what's happening in Ai.
The kind of cutting edge of ai at the
moment.
And even though I said earlier,
there are many unsolved problems too
that we have to still tackle even the
kinds of technologies we have today
already proving very useful.
So I'm just going to briefly mention a
few applications.
So obviously there are a whole host of
commercial applications that we and
others are looking at.
So helping with healthcare,
medical diagnostics,
we have a bunch of collaborations with
hospitals around the world are all sorts
of different areas,
especially with image recognition with
as work with optimization and energy.
We actually did some work for the Google
data centers and we managed to say 40
percent of the power the cooling systems
used by more efficiently controlling all
the all the cooling equipment.
I think there's lots of potential in
education for personalized education
using these ai systems and also with
virtual assistants on your phone and
making them a lot smarter.
So is it being used a lot in art and
design?
Many will.
You know about this.
So especially in architecture,
I believe that building the Opera House
on the left hand side here was designed
using machine learning as was the engine
block on the bottom right here for car
engine.
And also there's be some interesting
things in art,
art transfer,
transferring styles between different
art styles on the same picture as well
as creating art itself on the top
right.
And then for me,
my particular passion is using it for
science to accelerate scientific
endeavor and it's been used already
successfully.
These kinds of AI systems I've talked
about for discovering new exoplanets,
it's being used to try and control the
plasma and nuclear fusion reactors,
design new chemical compounds,
um,
and detect disease and things like
retina scans,
so whole host of areas in both medicine
and science.
That I think was just the beginning of,
I think we're going to see a huge
revolution over the next decade.
So just want to kind of close now by,
by just sort of going back to my initial
statements about our mission statement
and the way I think about that.
So I think of ai as kind of like a Meta
solution to a lot of the other problems
and challenges we have as a society.
So I think one of the big challenges we
face in all sorts of domains from
science also to,
into even things like entertainment is
information overload and system
complexity.
There's just so much.
We're kind of bombarded both in our
personal lives and our professional
lives with just overwhelming amounts of
information and data.
So how can we make sense of all of these
data streams?
And then the other thing is,
you know,
as a society we want to kind of
understand and master increasingly
complex systems,
some of which are boarding,
bordering on chaotic systems.
Things like a macroeconomics climate.
All of these areas where,
um,
you know,
these systems are incredibly complicated
that we would like to try and
understand.
And I think these are all huge
challenges that we have without
something like ai helping us.
And for a long while sort of the,
I guess the early two thousands,
the first decade of this century,
big data was this huge buzzword.
And I think in a way big data is the
problem.
You can think of an ai as the answer
because everyone has got tons of data
now or companies do and we all have tons
of data,
but what you do with all of that data,
how do you make sense of it?
And I think the only way to do that
actually at scale is to use ai and on
that level,
you know,
in a very general way you can think of
intelligence as a kind of process,
almost a magical process in some ways
that converts unstructured information
or data into useful actionable
knowledge.
That's what intelligence I think is
fundamentally.
And Ai is a kind of way of automating
that process.
And as I've mentioned my personal dream
and why I spent my whole career working
on ai is to use and build it as a
powerful tool to help the scientists and
experts and clinicians accelerate
desperately sort of needed scientific
breakthroughs.
Yeah.
So I think it's an incredibly sort of
exciting time and air holds incredible
promise for the future,
but you know,
it must be used responsibly and safely
just like any other powerful technology
and we have to ensure that it's used for
the benefit of everyone and the benefits
accrue to everyone.
You know,
I think of ai in it,
in of itself.
It's an inherently neutral technology
and just like with every,
any powerful technology depends how we
decide as a society to deploy it and use
it.
And on this topic,
I think a lot more research and
discussions needed with a wide set of
stakeholders.
And as I said,
as wise,
I think it's very important to have
dialogue like this between scientists
and technologists and artists and and
the social sciences.
And I think that's gonna be critical if
we're going to get this right for
everyone.
And we've started ourselves several
efforts both internally at deep mind.
We have an ethics and society group with
policy thinkers and philosophers and
ethicists,
and we've also been instrumental in co
founding,
a pan industry group called the
partnership on Ai,
which includes nonprofits and academics
as well as the big companies trying to
think about these topics for the benefit
of everyone in society.
So I just want to end this talk by
thinking a little bit.
We'll philosophy philosophically and for
me as a neuroscientist,
one or the other really interesting
things about this journey we're on is
that I believe that by trying to distill
intelligence into an algorithmic
constructs like we're doing with ai and
then if we use that and compare that to
the human brain,
I think that might help us better
understand what's unique about our own
minds,
including profound mysteries like the
nature of creativity that we've been
discussing,
what dreams are and perhaps even the big
questions like consciousness.
And uh,
as Richard Feynman said,
is one of my all time scientific heroes.
What I cannot create,
I do not truly understand.
And I think about that,
about intelligence.
And I just want to finish and give the
last word to find men actually and a
passage from one of his books that
really inspired me when I was a child to
think about science and arts and this is
the way I feel and it sort of echoes my
views on the topic.
And he said,
a fireman said,
well though I may not be quite as
refined aesthetically as my artist
friend is,
he was walking through a meadow with is
a good friend of his who was an artist
and they were looking at a flower and
they were discussing this and he said,
I can appreciate the beauty of a flower.
At the same time,
I can see much more about the flower.
I could imagine the cells in there,
the complicated action inside,
which also have a kind of beauty.
The fact that the colors in the flower
evolved in order to attract insects to
pollinate isn't is very interesting.
It means that these insects can see the
color.
All kinds of interesting questions with
the science knowledge only adds to the
excitement,
the mystery and the all of a flower.
And I think is really right about that
and that's why I love by science.
I cannot thank you.
Thank you.
Dummies is an academy here waiting to,
um,
not get at you,
but I'll ask you some questions,
but I just want to pick up on a couple
of points.
Your background was in gaming.
It was competitive.
You've come here,
I think in the spirit of collegiality,
of openness,
of a dialogue.
It was interesting in the,
in the go game,
Lisa Dol said that he felt he was there
defending human intelligence.
And last,
I think we've gone past the stage,
at least I hope we have the arts and
science are pitted against each other.
But do you think that element of
competitiveness that humans,
inevitable competitiveness is still
essential in developing what it is
you're trying to develop an establishing
relationships and knowledge between ai
and human creativity?
Yeah,
I mean,
look,
it's,
it's an interesting thing because
competitiveness is obviously when you
positively and constructively is,
is,
can be a very powerful driving force in
a very good one for progress.
In response to what Lisa Dole said,
I can understand why he felt like that
because he was representing the Ngo
world and it was quite surprising for
him.
You know,
he's definitely at least a decade before
he was expecting that to happen.
But one thing you gotta remember is that
of course Alphago is a human endeavor to
and there are all sorts of amazing
programs and researchers on the team who
were,
who spent their whole lives building up
their skills in the way Lisa Dole had in
his art to be able to program something
that the architecture behind Alphago,
which then went on to learn for itself,
but it,
of course all the initial conditions was
created by by human scientists.
So I think the whole thing,
and if you see the film as a
celebration,
I think of the spirit of human endeavor
from all sides,
from the goplayers,
the programmers,
everyone kind of collaborating together,
including actually the journalists and
writers who were writing about the
match.
In fact,
that might want to.
Some of my favorite pieces of writing
were done by a wire journalist who was
writing.
I thought very poetically about the
whole mash as he was watching it live,
so I think it's actually a wonderful
celebration of human ingenuity all
around and and I think you know,
after the match,
since then,
if you taught him,
he ends,
he's had time to reflect on that and I
think it's been amazing for the go.
Well they've.
They've unleashed their own creativity
because not only are they playing what's
called like Alphago,
like moves also,
many of the top go players I've spoken
to has said was felt that there is free
their minds from the shackles of
tradition,
so they're all trying to think the
unthinkable now and they've come up with
their own brilliant new ideas that in
the thousands of years and hundreds of
years past,
they have been told as as junior go,
players not to not to do and sort of be
told off for it and now they're able to
explore their own creativity
without peddling a stereotype,
which is always a precluding to peddling
a stereotype.
The world loves the notion of randomness
and chance.
He wants to harness it and possibly for
many artists here,
certainly for me,
and I'm not an artist.
That moment where the commentator
thought that a mistake had been made
becomes really interesting.
Less the resolution you saw the beauty,
but more the fact that Beckett's idea of
failing or failing,
Metta lies at the heart of many people's
creative vision,
see it as impossible pursuit of
perfection.
Whereas certain scientists theaters a
potential pursuit of perfection.
Again,
that's a stereotyping.
Our predicates itself in certain areas
of having no rules of wanting to break
the rules,
that almost becomes a tedious job,
but actually at its best it offers
endless possibilities.
At its worst.
It's an anoxic void of meaninglessness.
And how does that play into your pursuit
of understanding human created?
Well,
I think that's what I was talking about
or trying to talk about where the types
of creativity.
So I think the breaking of all the rules
and breaking outside of,
you know,
going beyond what the rules allow you to
do.
That for me would be true invention,
which I was kind of having as the yellow
door outside the box and I think our
systems currently are not capable of
that,
right?
They're capable of of being creative,
but within the rules so to speak,
which is what I was sort of meaning by
extrapolation,
so here's the rules of go come up with
some new motifs of new strategies and
new tactics and new theories and it was
able to do that that we're genuinely
new,
so I think that is a genuine form of
creativity but not the highest level of
creativity,
which would be something like coming up
with go in the first place.
I think there are many people in this
room who would love ai to take over the
role of the critic and I think the
notion of criticism,
how we judge things,
human taste,
how we decide that something is more
interesting or better than another is an
inexact science.
It can be a poetry,
but it's in an exact science.
How does that play into your thinking?
What I think some aspects of aesthetic
judgment could potentially be learned by
these systems.
You've given enough training data,
you know,
maybe there was some amazing art critic
or restaurant critic that you wanted to
kind of mimic the judgment of and maybe
given enough data.
Some of those aspects could be judged,
could be sort of mimicked in some way,
but I think it was still go beyond that
because when I went to an art critics
judging arts,
one of the things that I,
I regard about human created our why
she's.
Why I think it's higher than machine
created are,
is the part from the technicalities of
it is that there's always the imprint of
the artists through their artwork and I
think some of the soul of the artist
come through that art and that's what
we're appreciating as human viewers of
the art and where perhaps the art critic
too.
So I always think of someone like Van
Gough,
his,
this sort of the tortured nature of his
soul comes for almost every brush stroke
he,
he has.
And that's one of the reasons why his
art so incredible.
And I think it wouldn't be the same even
if a machine could match it technically,
which obviously is a big f anyway in of
itself because I think part of what's
great about artists,
the is the is the sort of the,
the,
the imprint of what they,
of what the artist has experienced in
creating the art.
Well,
I mean there are many things that can
affirm,
but one of them is the affirmation that
I'm here,
I'm alive.
What it is to be human wrestling with
the human condition.
Presumably a machine can't do that.
But presumably you're arguing that at
some stage in the not too distant
future,
it might be able to have a semblance of
that.
Or is that nonsense?
What's the timeframe?
I mean months,
years.
You'll obviously say not,
but is there a sense that we're looking
at something approaching this in the
next decade?
No,
I think,
I mean aspects of it in the next
decades.
But I mean,
I think this is what I mentioned at the
end really about what fascinates me is
both a neuroscientist and a computer
scientist is that,
you know,
what are these aspects of the brain
that,
that mechanism cannot be done
computationally.
Are there any and if they are,
what are they and what mechanisms do
they use can be explained or is this
something mysterious?
And I'm quite open minded about that and
I think what I see is part of what we're
doing,
which is this neuroscience inspired ai,
is let's see where that takes us.
And then we'll see which aspects remain
that only the human brain can do.
And you know,
I think about that for creativity.
I think about that for a dreams.
I think about that for consciousness.
We don't know what these things are,
the nature of consciousness.
We don't know how they manifest
themselves in,
in,
in the physics of our brain.
There are theories,
but we don't know.
And I think this may be one way of,
uh,
of,
of examining that is I'm trying to build
aspects of intelligence and then seeing
what was missing.
And some of those things,
you know,
maybe impossible,
although for,
for the moment,
um,
you know,
at least from a biological point of
view,
that doesn't seem to be anything long
computable in the brain,
although there's speculation about that.
There's a famous mathematician called
Roger Penrose who talks about quantum
consciousness and he thinks there are
quantum effects in the brain,
in which case if he's right,
then we will not be able to model those
on a conventional computer.
Traditional classical computer.
But so far,
and biologists have looked for this
quite hard there,
that they,
no one's found any quantum effects in
the brain so far.
I love the idea that the computer would
not,
it would,
we'd have to do,
is learn to invent,
reinvent,
go itself May.
Maybe in the end it will reinvent.
But are one of these art does,
is constantly reinvents itself.
You've already given us about six
potential lectures.
I'm not so cheeky or opportunistic to
ask you to come back and give series
here,
but you should do really.
But I'm also conscious that there are
people here in the brief time we have
left now,
you will have questions to make
questions to ask of you and I do think
there should be another forum to,
to,
to look through the implications of much
of what you said could,
could ask people to ask questions rather
than make long statements.
I know that's difficult because there's
so much that's been thrown out,
but I'd love to take some questions from
the floor.
Could you wait for the mic?
There's a hand up at the back there.
Thank you.
Hi.
A great lecture.
And following on from what you were just
discussing,
uh,
you said at the beginning that's a
reinforcement learning.
We know that that model can lead to a
general intelligence.
And so I was wondering if,
if,
uh,
in order to,
to get the general intelligence and the
higher level of creativity like
invention,
do you think we need to,
to work out consciousness and
intentionality and do you agree with
philosophers like John Self new say,
um,
that,
uh,
we need to understand the,
the,
the physical material of the brain
rather than just the algorithm?
No,
I.
So I disagree with John Cell and um,
I do think that you can make progress on
this question without fully
understanding the substrate and fat.
I,
I believe that intelligence will be
substrate independent in the sense that
we are forced to learning is the way
we're going to try and build it.
But there are probably other ways of
building intelligence.
They're more mathematical,
less neuroscience based,
and even the neuroscience based way like
we're doing,
you know,
we're really looking at the systems
level,
the algorithmic level,
not at the actual wetware itself,
the exact way that neurons work and
cortical columns.
Other people are doing that.
That's sometimes called whole brain
emulation where you're effectively
trying to reverse engineer the brain's
precisely and implement it in the same
way the brain does.
And I don't believe that will be
necessary for intelligence as to whether
we'll need consciousness for true
creativity and other things.
I'm not sure I,
I,
if I was,
you know,
I think there's a open scientific
question and we need to get further with
the research to understand that.
But I would say that if I was to bet on
it,
um,
I think it's likely that intelligence
and consciousness are what's called
double dissociable.
So I think you'll be able to have
intelligent systems that will,
that we fantastically intelligent in
terms of the capability but will not
feel conscious in any way in the way
that I do to you.
You do.
To me.
And I also think on the other end of the
spectrum,
if you look at animals,
for example,
like our pets,
like dogs and cats and so on,
I think it's pretty clear they have
fought some form of consciousness.
You see them dreaming and,
and they seem to have those kinds of
traits or self awareness and other
things,
but obviously they're not close to human
level intelligence.
So it seems as though maybe the
dissociable traits,
but um,
you know,
who,
who knows,
maybe we'll get in 20 years time,
we'll get to a point where we are okay,
we're sort of stuck against the brick
wall and actually the reason we can't
have more intelligent systems is we now
understand what this consciousness thing
is.
Thank you for questions.
Beautifully balanced systematically.
Yeah.
Gentlemen that and then.
Hi,
thanks for the great lecture.
Um,
do you think that the current speed of
ai research has had a negative impact on
its practices in the field and if so,
what do you think can be done about it
tag mean negative on,
on its own in terms of its applications?
Yeah.
No,
I don't think so.
I think it's mostly been positive.
I would say,
um,
I think like with any,
any hot topic and that's,
I think it's a bit too hyped and I think
that's caused a lot of um,
you know,
the sorts of bad cycles you get when,
when,
uh,
when uh,
an area gets to the top of the hype
cycle.
So I think there's been a lot of amazing
work that's happened,
but some of the promises are over
promising still compared to where we
are.
Um,
and I think that sometimes can lead to
some bad silence this rushed or in some
way,
but I think mostly the community is
actually very good.
The research community around Ai and
it's very open.
Everyone publishes everything and I
think it's pretty collegiate at the
moment.
So I would say the research communities
actually pretty solid.
And I actually think in order for us to
get to better practice best practices
and protocols that say around how these
systems are deployed,
I actually think we need to get further
with the systems.
So we have concrete systems to
experiment on and actually figure out
because compete science isn't,
it's not theoretical subjects in
engineering discipline.
So in order for us to make progress with
that,
I think we have to have systems that we
can actually test empirically test and I
think all the best science is done with
empirical work in tandem with
theoretical work and for us the
empirical work is engineering.
Yes.
Thank you for the lecture.
I think I need an ai to help me process
all the information you've just given us
in the last hour.
I'd like to take you back to your art
and science comment at the beginning.
So have you looked at using Gq n two
instead of trying to recreate three
dimensional computer graphics,
potentially recreate architecture or
environments that live longer exist,
whether it's because of war or just you
know,
dilapidation there's,
there's a lot of amazing art in the
world architecture that has been lost
and there are a lot of paintings and
photographic representations of that.
And is it something you guys had looked
at in terms of trying to help us
recapture some of that?
Yeah,
we have started to look at that.
So as I mentioned where we gq and we're
now trying to build up to more complex
scenes in and eventually we're world
architecture would be a very interesting
to try and like a room or in a
dilapidated room in a,
in a,
in,
in a structure.
Another area that's been worked on a lot
is what's called generative models,
which gun is an example where they're
trying to fill in pictures or even drop
photos and things where they try to,
um,
you know,
you can leave a missing part and it will
fill it in and they're not photo
realistic yet.
They're not as good as the originals.
You know,
you would obviously spot it immediately
as a generated by computer,
but they're getting better all the time.
And one of the issues is with
architectures are anything more complex
than our simple scenes is the system
still don't really understand the
semantics of a scene.
So they don't really understand that
these objects are separate and what
background is and for ground and so on.
And,
and how physics interacts with
structures.
And that's the concept part I was
talking about.
And I think systems like gun,
if they had abstractions and concepts
would start being able to pass the late
the world up into semantic meaning and
structure,
which then allow them to model much more
complicated sentence.
So I think that's what's holding us back
right now.
But eventually I would expect to be able
to do those kinds of things
we should say the US was always harness
technology and recently of painting was
made by Algorithms.
And all I can say is,
well it might've made it into the summer
exhibition.
Yeah.
Thank you very much for that.
I just wanted to ask you a question
about explainability.
So you mentioned about the move the
Alphago made.
That was after the fact that go experts
could say,
oh,
we know why it did that,
but you could also probably imagine
situations where it would be harder to
understand why a machine had made a
decision that it did.
Um,
do you think it's important to build
systems that are able to explain
themselves?
Or do you think it's natural that we're
going to kind of decouple away from
machines and will kind of lose a bit of
that agency?
No,
I think it's great question.
I think it's incredibly important that
we have interpretability and our systems
for a couple of reasons.
One is it's useful to advance the
science if the better you understand the
current systems obviously in what are
their,
their limitations are,
but for any,
uh,
once you start deploying these ai
systems for any safe safety critical
application,
of course you would need to understand
why the decision was made and I would
actually advocate further and always
have a human in the loop to make the
final decision and think of the Ai as a
tool that provides information to that
ultimate human decision maker.
Um,
and in order to do that,
we need to explain these black box
systems better and I don't worry about
that as much as other people.
So I think we're just going through a
phase at the moment where you can think
of it in terms of the evolution of AI
systems as in the last decade.
There's been a huge explosion of ai
systems that are really good now and can
do interesting things.
Um,
but that's very new.
And uh,
the,
the challenge in that they know the last
10 years has been can we get these
systems working at all?
Nevermind about interpretability now we
have the working,
we have something to work on,
reverse engineer and analyze now asks
and many other teams around the world
are concentrating on building analysis
tools.
So we're being analysis tools,
visualization tools,
all sorts of things.
Even doing behavioral testing like more
like you'd have in a psychology lab,
you know,
to look,
think about both behaviorally testing
it,
looking into the architecture,
measuring it,
almost like a doing brain analysis like
neuroscience,
but on an artificial brain.
And so with all those tools are very,
very embryonic right now because I've
only been in the last couple of years of
this being started to be worked on.
And I'm pretty sure I'm pretty confident
that with another sort of five years of
work on those kinds of tools,
a lot of these systems right now that
look quite black box,
black box systems will become
sustainable and adaptable.
So,
uh,
you know,
I think it's vital,
but I think we're just a bit on the
starting point of that and you know,
I wouldn't worry too much about that at
the moment.
A lot of these systems are quite black
box.
We've been rigorously program to stick
to now we've crushed through it.
Let's be knocking.
Take one more question.
You going to say one more question?
Let's take the,
the woman that
then we can carry on over a drink.
He said offering up that misty will.
Okay.
Thank you.
Last word has always been pretty fearful
of ai thing.
There were presentations,
things like westward and terminator,
etc.
And I'm very glad that you mentioned
ethics.
Just whAt do you think of the artworks
for presentation of ai and how,
how your advIse on preventing that kind
of future from happening?
Yeah,
I think the art world,
it would be nice if there were,
if it was a little bit more creative in
some sense,
right,
because I think it's easy to.
I mean it's obviously more dramatic to
have a,
you know,
dystopian futures and villains and so
on.
It's obviously creates more excitement.
Um,
but obviously that's a,
you know,
I think it's,
most of those scenarios are pure science
fiction and we shouldn't worry about
them too much.
I think that we actually need a lot of
science fiction can be very helpful in
terms of lots of scientists,
including myself who inspired by science
fiction to make some of the things they
read.
Certainly for me,
I read probably too much science fiction
when I was young to try and make that
come true and there are actually
brilliant books about futures which with
ais and humans in them that have really
interesting worlds like ian banks,
great writer his and also ask them off
not his robot stories,
which I've never read.
Actually there is that.
Things like the foundation series,
which is more serious scifi I think is
very interesting and it will be useful I
think,
to have to explore the whole spectrum of
possibilities with ai rather than this
sort of quite crude,
a narrow way of exploring it.
And I didn't particularly like westworld
for example.
I think it's pretty boring and obvious.
I think it's a good note on which to end
the scientist comes into the royal
academy and says that the outward needs
to be more creative and that actually
will accept science fiction and
hollywood films and television as part
of the broad visual culture.
Um,
we've Just finished a festival of ideas
were in the main artistic practitioners.
Philosophers,
theorists have come to the academy.
We need to expand our networks.
We need to get out more.
We certainly need to generate more
discussions with scientists at the
cutting edge of artificial intelligence,
among other things.
We probably need to make this place a
forum where human consciousness gets
debated and you'd be a great person to
do that.
But for this evening,
dennis hassabis,
thank you so much.
Thank you.